there was a time in our town when
somebody got a hot tub
and people had never said they couldn't
imagine what what what is it
somebody's like it's like a little ocean
in your yard and it's
you know you put it down
you know it's like warm it's like a
little
damn soup
and so people were fired up you know and
and opening night i didn't get to go to
opening night at it there was more
adults going there and seeing it and
drinking wine buy it and
you know people would press a button and
turn it on
and then turn it off like oh let's go
look at it
they'll gotta have what's green
you know people bobbing for apples in it
you know drinking and then
maybe your buddy's wife's over there
bobbing and nobody's looking and you go
touch her ass a little or something
or play crack hand or something for a
second with her you know or whatever i
don't know
i don't know what the neighborhood was
like i didn't go to opening night
but the next day they let the children
get in it
you know when i was a child and so i got
in there and
you know we're all in there and we were
children as many many kids as you could
fit into a damn little hot tub
and this i think this fella this thing
probably seated seven i don't know
when you're a kid everything seats seven
seventy seven hundred you know your
children so it doesn't matter if there's
people next to you or on your whatever
you know little lawrence will be in
there and he'll be wearing little
freaking anthony as a scarf and
they got nine other kids you know they
got twins in there and
somebody goes in and comes out as
triplets it doesn't who knows it's just
being children that was just
you know the
the connective energy amongst children
is
it's not as
it's very strong
you know as we when we get as we become
adults i find i be i become more of a
proton or a neutron but
when you're young you're just part of
the electricity
so anyway we had a bunch of children in
there and
we'd never been in a hot tub people
didn't know you know people drinking the
water and doing all you know washing
their hair and
one kid you know his dad come over and
baptize him on the side and people just
living in one fella brought a fish it
died immediately because of the heat
but people didn't know we didn't know
we weren't enjoying it
and the directions got all wet
immediately so nobody knew what they
said
and we were just hot tubbing and
pretending we were in fans somebody
wrote tahiti on the
on a sign and nailed it to the tree
right there and god we were living it up
and there was one fella named cj
and he was older than us he was probably
he could have been 15 he could have been
60.
you know he had those
he had scars on his back i don't he
might have been a slave you know he's a
white guy but he might have been
enslaved at one point i don't know he'd
been through a lot
you know you've been through a lot and
i remember he had hair kind of around
the top of his pants on the back
and uh
so anyway we're all in the hot tub we're
enjoying it we're probably maybe 10 or
12 i don't know 11.
and big cj been under the water he'd
been touching his body
you know and he'd been prepping his body
to really eat jack out
and spray you know i'm really just
bust full you know
and i'm not a pedophile or anything i'm
just telling you a story from my
childhood so
you know i was there and i was a child
and when this happened anyway so he
he's prepping his body under water the
rest of us don't know we're doing back
strokes you know we're doing uh one
guy's filling his mouth with water
shooting it in the air somebody else is
catching it
you know people just having a good time
it's like a little las vegas out there
it's like our own little uh
uh bellagio
you know we're doing it all
and
cj been prepping his body to bust out
well at one point he stands up in the
hot tub and ejects
out into the water and we've never seen
it
we're like what
we've never seen
you know i think i'd only ever even seen
anybody else's penis that but probably
my brother
i'd seen my own penis in a mirror but
that's just your you know that's still
your penis it's not
you know it's still yours it's just one
and then i'd seen some other kid's penis
through like a fire he was on the other
side of a fire and i was on one side
but um
yeah this kid stood up and he knew about
it
and he so he you know he's e-jacking out
into the pond or whatever and uh
and my buddy will was right there
and will was a sweet guy man and he just
he he thought something was happening to
this kid
to this cj but he thought he was dying i
guess
you know he thought well if this you
know
if he pumps out another
20 or 30 servings he's gonna you know
each time he gets going to get smaller
and smaller he's disappearing
you know
and i could see in that moment how that
all registered it was like oh my gosh
this guy's
you know this guy's uh
eventually his whole body will shoot out
of the end of his
wiener
so we didn't know what to do man so will
grabbed it
will grabbed it to really stop it off at
the end like a hose you know like where
you
bend a hose like that
and the fella punched him man fell
unloaded unloaded on him
so and that was a lot man that was a lot
for one moment in time because we never
i'd never seen any of that i'd never
you know to see such
you know a moment of kind of sexual
advancement at that and experience that
and then also
see a saving you know this real saving
grace this real
this two-handed angel
you know come in and try to save this
boy's life to keep his
body inside of his body to keep him
from just dripping out his existence
into the world and then to see the the
abuse at the end and you know it's kids
man
and that's kids brother but uh
but god man
god life is uh
there's a lot of gravel on the road
isn't there
and will we love you man and i just want
to let you know that you are loved
brother
and uh
and you'll be missed man you were always
you were always up for the up for the up
for a good time man i feel like you were
always
and not just any time you're always
pretty positive man and hopeful and uh
and you will be missed
this fellow that passed though he had
we'd been in a hot tub i've told this
story before this is i like how every
one of your stories is like yeah i
remember this as a kid now he has since
passed
well yeah
oh everybody dies man that i know
but
he we the first time anybody ever
ejaculated in our in our we were at a
party and someone did it in a hot tub
and none of us had ever seen it
we didn't know about it we didn't know
you could do it yeah
so this guy was erect under the water
and he was doing like a remember loch
ness monster the drawing yeah it was
very funny cool it was like the biggest
most important thing
he kept doing that a little bit just
loch nests in his wiener out the hot
that's very funny it was pretty cool man
yeah especially at that age we're done
now he has since passed
he is still alive this guy
but at one point he was i guess
pleasuring himself he leans up out of
the water
starts spraying out
this other kid thought something was
happening to him that was bad grabbed
his penis to stop it from happening no
and the other the bigger kid ended up
punching the kid but the kid that
grabbed him the safety king
the safety kid died
they say the kid who grabbed the penis
and got punched yeah he is overdosed
yeah he grabbed the he saw an
ejaculating penis he went because he
didn't know he thought he's got a bad
end to this yes
then he got punched too and died hell
was [__] it's a terrible story it's a
tough life story
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one